hi my name is natasha carp and i'm a
biostatistician for master zenica
i'd like to thank the organizers for
inviting me to talk about sex bias and
pre-clinical research
why it exists and then explore how to
drive change
first of all i'd like to consider sex as
a biological variable
explore the prevalence of sex having
impacts on our experiments
then explore why sex bias might exist in
our practices
consider the sociological exploration of
the topic
and then look at the challenges of
changing practice
so let's start at the beginning sex is a
biological variable
the neglect of sex within individual
preclinical research is well established
in the literature there are numerous
papers raising the issue throughout our
research pipeline
for example if we look in reporting a
paper in 2014
surveyed a number of manuscripts and
found that 22 percent
did not specify the sex and animals that
they were using in their studies
if we look instead of experimental
design a paper in 2011
looked across 10 fields of biology and
found that on average 80
of the animals were male rodents
in 2015 missouri and jones raised the
point that the sex fires have not
changed in over a 20-year period which
means the literature has been talking
about it
for over 20 years and then if we focus
on the analysis of data
even if we do collect both sexes there's
a tendency to discard that in the
analysis
and pull the data together in one bunch
and this isn't specific to the in vivo
world but also occurs in the in vitro
studies
so again we see around 70 plus of papers
don't report the sex of the cells that
they're studying
and in the design it's predominantly
male only cells that are being used
and in fact when you look at the
provision of the cells majority of cells
are solved without defining the sex
because it's not considered a relevant
piece of information
so when i first started thinking and
talking about sex as a biological
variable
people said to me but surely when it's
female prevalent diseases
we would use female animals and i
thought well yeah but okay i'm going to
look in the literature see if anybody's
research that particular question and
that question was answered in 2014
in the review by eon and he looked at
45 he
looked papers published in surgical
biomedical research between 2011 and
2012.
for publications on female prevalent
diseases of which he had 45
44 did not report the sex studied
and for those that reported the sex only
12 percent studied females
so now even if it is a female pregnant
disease it wouldn't necessarily follow
that we would use female animals for the
research
now we know from our own experiences
that the prevalence of the disease the
symptoms we're going to experience the
progression of the disease and the side
effects that we might experience
depend on our sex and we can see that in
a piece of research published in 2001
exploring the drugs that have been
withdrawn from the us market between
1997 and 2000
and they found that the predominant
reason was because of greater health
risks for women
compared to men and these health risks
weren't
minor side effects they were
life-altering disfiguring surgical
complications
birth defects in babies and onset of
chronic diseases
and this we can see in the impact on the
adverb drug reaction
in that a comparison between the males
and females find a statistically
significant difference
with an odds ratio of 1.6 that women
will experience
a adverse drug reaction compared to men
now we talk about personalizing medicine
and we focus on genes
and you know genetics well actually we
could just focus on the sex of a person
and have a significant impact if we
consider this in our pipeline
so in 2014 the nih in the u.s
the national institute of health took
the unusual step
that instead of recommending that we
include sex as a biological variable as
so many funding bodies had before
they mandated it they said if you want
funding from us
you're going to have to balance the sex
in your cells and animal studies
so what did they ask they said we need
to include females
you need to analyze by sex and they
coined the phrase
sex as a biological variable they also
made this mandate for both cells
and in vivo studies and this is very
relevant because
the nih are the largest funders of
biomedical research in the world
so what was their expectations
now the thing to note here is that
they're not asking us
to understand how the treatment effect
depends on sex
what they're asking us to do is to
always include both sexes
so if there is a big difference then you
will be able to see that difference when
you visualize and analyze the data
and it could set off a whole new path of
research
and they defined rigorously defined
exceptions
scenarios when you wouldn't need to
study both sexes
so what are those exceptions okay if
you're working with pure molecular
studies such as how proteins interact it
doesn't matter the source material and
whether you got them from males or
females
if you are looking at sex-specific
conditions such as ovarian cancer of
course
sex is not a rare and relevant variable
if you're working with acutely scarce
resources such as non-human primates it
would be justifiable to study only one
set
and they did have to provide of course
you know the other statement
if you can provide strong justification
but they were very explicit to say
absence of evidence regarding sex
differences
is not justification if you have not
seen a sex difference
to date that doesn't mean that you can
just start studying one sex that means
you keep studying both sexes and
estimating from the both the treatment
effects
and if an effect occurs you will be
ready to see it
now the reason they're asking us to do
this
is um for example because of this sort
of issue here
and here i wanted to explore the impact
of pooling our data together
so what i've done is i've artificially
constructed some data
that has a defined mean and variance and
i've added a sex effect for only one sex
and then on the left i've just pulled
that data together
and what you see after the treatment is
that the variance looks a little bit
higher but
not significantly so that could easily
happen in an experiment
and you wouldn't see a difference in the
mean but as soon as you
visualize your data by sex you
immediately see well
actually that does depend on one of the
sex but not the others
so this is the what they're pushing for
we need to visualize data by sex
and we need to statistically include a
term to ask whether the effect depends
on sex
now of course this push from the nhs was
greeted with a lot of controversy the
numerous papers
raising issues with this proposal and i
particularly like the paper published in
2014 by professor field
who stated it was a major step in the
wrong direction it was a waste of
resources
and we were scientists and we should be
trusted to know what we're doing
but if we think of the work by johnson
in plus one 2014 what they raised is
there's a knowledge gap
if we've always been studying one sex
then how would we know whether this
variable depended on sex we sort of just
got a pattern of behavior
that we wouldn't know we have a
knowledge gap
and at this point in time i was working
with a large data set that actually had
both sexes and i thought aha
this is something that i could actually
answer with this data set
so let's explore that so assessing the
prevalence of sexual dimorphism
so i was working with the international
mouse phenotyping consortium
which is a group from all over the world
working together
to knock out every single mass coding
protein coding gene in the genome
and to then characterize the resulting
mice line with a broad
set of tests so that we could relate the
genotype to the phenotype
and for each knockout line you were
making you would generate seven females
and seven male knockout lines and we
generated
both because we were breeding the
animals in house and so we studied both
because otherwise we'd just be throwing
away one of the sexes
and what you can see on that graph on
the right the diagram on the right
is the sort of tests that were happening
for those animals
so for example at week nine you will be
conducting
tests such as open field to look at
their behavior when they run around a
box
or grip strength whilst at week 14
you're looking at body composition
in week 16 you've got variables such as
heart weight or the clinical blood
chemistry parameters
so it's a broad spectrum of biology is
being explored
and this work was that i'm going to
present now was published
in 2017 in nature communication and to
give you a sense of the scale of the
data that i was working with
i had data from 14 000 different wild
type mice
40 000 different knockout mice that
looked across
over 2 000 different knockout lines
looking up to 234 traits
and so the idea here is i'm not asking
for a particular treatment
does sex have a role in explaining the
effect but rather
if we look at a whole if we were running
any tough experiments how often would
sex have a role
because this is just a representative
sample of people doing experiments
so there's two ways we can ask this
question in the data the role of sex as
a biological variable we can first
ask how often does it change the
behavior of the data in the control data
such that if you pooled the data and
didn't include those terms in the
analysis you would be making mistakes
and having you could be making having
causality issues
interpreting your data so we have two
types of variables
in this pipeline we have continuous
variables such as
lean mass or sodium level and we have
categorical variables
such as the rib shape is abnormal
compared to
normal so if we look at the first the
categorical variables which is normal
versus abnormal we were in the pipeline
looking for rare events where the
knockout of the gene would learn to an
increase in the abnormality rate
but we were surprised to find that even
in the control data
there was a difference in the
abnormality rate between the males and
females
for 10 percent of the times and
sometimes the abnormality rates higher
in the males and sometimes in the
females
if we think instead about the continuous
variables such as the sodium level or
the body weight
again we see a difference between males
and females but for 60 percent of the
variables
sometimes the mean was running higher
one than the other
but maybe more interesting to ask how
often did sex
modify the treatment effect and here
we've got two pie graphs one for
categorical and one for continuous
and the this is a pie graph of when we
first detected a
statistically significant effect in
looking at the gene we then asked
did it depend on the sex so this is
showing of the ones that were
statistically significant
did it depend on the sex the effect and
we find for the categorical that 13
of the time it did sometimes the
abnormality rate was higher for the
knockouts in the males
and sometimes it was higher than the
females and with the continuous
variables it was around 15
and this time it was more it wasn't more
that it was in one sex only per se it
was more that it could be a different
size between the two now we only had
seven males and seven females for each
knockout gene
so that just we weren't particularly
empowered to see
a sexual dimorphism in the treatment
effect
so this indicates that the effect is
quite prevalent and so sexual dimorphism
is interacting with our treatment
effects at a high proportion of our
experiments
so then why does a sex bias exist in our
practice and how we run our experiments
and i would argue that this arises from
some misconceptions
some skill gaps practical concerns
and the 3r interpretation i'm going to
focus on the 3r interpretations because
for animal experiments that's actually
one of the major players that's playing
out with how we conduct our experiments
when we run experiments we have to
isolate cause and effect by
simplification
we have to choose where we're going to
simplify and we simplify down
to a standardized space with the only
difference is the treatment and there's
always a decision point
where we do that because of the 3rf
recall framework
we also need to simplify so that we can
draw decisions
but we've got a lot of pressure to
minimize the number of animals used for
experiments
so under the three hours and the
reduction element of our ethical
decision making process the historic
interpretation of reduction was
to minimize the number of animals used
per experiment
and you would see conversations in the
ethical review boards discussing whether
to use
seven or five animals per group in
experiments and a lot of energy focused
on this
now it doesn't so if you can cut down
from seven and five that's considered
a three-hour benefit and something that
is highly valued
yet it doesn't count the fact that if
you've used five males here
there have been females bred in that
process that are then being discarded
because they don't get counted in your
number it's the numbers you use within
your experiments
and the fact that you can't actually
answer the question for the females
isn't considered relevant either because
you're focused within this experiment
using as few as animals as possible
and if you only focus on one sect people
perceive that they could use less
animals
now there is now a change in the
definition reduction but it hasn't
actually become truly embedded in our
culture
and this was proposed by the nc3rs to
appropriately design and analyze
animal experiments that are robust and
reproducible and truly add
to the knowledge base it doesn't talk
about n anymore
it talks about having value in the
experience being sure that the
experiment is valuable
and therefore justifiable because the
data is going to add to the knowledge
base
so there's often a question well why did
they choose male
animals and not female animals if we
were going to just choose one sex to
have a simpler testing space and reduce
the number why did it always end up
being males
and that's because of the misconception
that female rice
female mice would be hormonal and
because of this hormonal
variability in the mice they could be at
different stages of their cycle they
would be more bearable
now this is actually a wives tale if we
the piece of research published in 2014
was a meta-analysis looking at 293
published articles where they had
studied both sexes
and it compared the variance between the
males and the females that were not
and were at any point in their cycle of
their estrogen cycle so they were random
stages
and what they found is that when they
did a global analysis and this is shown
in diagram a on the top on the right
there was no statistically significant
difference
between the variance scene of the female
and the males
and if we instead look at individual
variables
we do find three variables that are
significantly different
but that's because the variance is
higher in the males not
the females so this is a very
embedded cultural concept that females
are more variable but isn't actually
evidence-based
females are no more variable than males
and that shouldn't be used as a
justification that you should only focus
on males in your research
the other theories and that i think
people focus on one sex is that if you
study one sex you have a control group
and a treated group
you can explore the data it's very
simple to visualize
it's very simple to analyze so you're
basically
in we're looking at one sex you've got a
for a continuous variable a student t
test you're looking at the variation the
variable of interest why
it depends on the treatment you can do
this in excel it's very easy
however if you move to both sexes you're
now doing a
two-way anova you're asking what is the
effect of treatment
after accounting for any sex differences
and does that treatment effect depend on
sex
can't do this in excel you now need to
uh use statistical software
and in reality for our biological
communities is that we've had
very limited training in our degrees and
phds in experimental design and
statistical analysis
and we can see that in that statements
like 4 out of 10 americans
will publicly say that they hate
mathematics mathematics anxiety is
recognized as a physiological condition
and if each time you add an equation to
your manuscript you will get 28
fewer citations it is socially
acceptable
for a biologist to say that they hate
statistics and mathematics
yet we actually need it for our research
and our everyday
studies so i perceive that this is a
skill gap that is playing out
inhibiting people from embracing these
more complex designs
one of the other issues i would like to
raise is the misconception that it will
double my animal usage if i say to
someone
okay but why don't you run the
experiment with both sexes they say but
that would be double the number and i
just can't afford it but the actual
advice is to keep doing what you're
already doing but change half the
animals in your study to females
and people go but how can you do that
your statistical power won't be high
enough
and that's because you're moving from a
randomized complete design
to a factorial design when you're
working
in the diagram on the left which is for
a single sex you are estimating your
treatment effect between the control
group
and the treated group alone but when
you're working in a factorial design
you'll be estimating your treatment
effect
after accounting for the sex differences
from both the males and the females
and that is why the impact on power is
not as significant as you would
initially
expect
now there are a lot of the things there
that we're saying that are
misconceptions or their skills gaps but
actually there is
some issues with stepping up your
experiments from studying one sex to two
sexes
you have increased the complexity of
your experiment particularly when the
fact that we're dealing with living
creatures um we to manage the welfare of
our animals say rodents
we cage them by their own sex so that
they're not lonely
which means if you're going to try and
reduce order effects with time
you can't keep going in and out of cages
because one you're going to make
mistakes and two you're going to
distress the animals so you have to
process them by cage but how do you
minimize order effects
how do you manage the fact that the
pheromones of the female animals might
impact the male animals
should you clean the equipment between
the sexes or should you make a scent
client
you know so there are lots of issues and
practical concerns
will the exposure to the female animals
increase fighting between the males
which becomes then a welfare concern
now the solutions to this are going to
be very dependent on your environment
you have closed cages do you have open
cages what exact tests are you running
but people out there are running
experiments with both sexes so we need
to find out practically on the ground
exactly how they're doing it
and that is information we need to share
because we need to work at the right
decision to balance how to
run these experiments practically with
both sexes but manage the welfare of the
animals appropriately
now one of the things i wanted to touch
upon is that in the beginning i said
this
the nih was requesting this change to
both sexes for both in vivo and in vitro
and that's because we can see within the
in vitro community that there's a
similar bias
the use of male cells so what's driving
that
behavior in our research pipeline and i
believe that's a misconception that the
sex of the cell is irrelevant
and that usually when you raise you know
some evidence people go oh
oh yeah of course i hadn't thought of
that
you know and that's because people
believe that once you take the sound
away from a hormonal environment that it
doesn't matter whether it's male or
females but now with our thoughts about
epigenetics and gene expression we do
you know there's much more evidence
suggests that it it's not just the
hormones driving the difference
it's at a genetic level and there was a
piece of research that i published in
2007 was a really nice example of
demonstrating how sex matters and this
was looking at um stem cells treatment
for muscular dystrophy in an animal
model
and they were having real variability in
their response
and you know they could have just walked
away from the experiment but instead
they decided to explore
where the variability occurred and they
ran a factorial design
and what they found was that the ability
to trigger regeneration
depended both on the sex of the donor
and the sex of the recipients
and that the female cells were much more
robust to the process leading to a
better outcome than the male cells
you know so this insight opens the door
to further opportunities for research
but if they hadn't thought about sex as
a biological variable
they would have easily missed this
so you know we've reviewed the challenge
the sex bias in our pipelines and seen
that it's well established both in vivo
and in vitro
so what we need to now consider is the
challenge of change why is it we have
manuscripts that have been talking about
these issues
for many years with no progress and no
change in the practice
in our labs around the world and the
work that i'm going to talk about here
has been written up in an article in the
british journal of pharmacology
so i'm going to explore a number of
management techniques to help us
understand
why change is difficult or what we can
do to drive that change
and one of the things i want to start
with is the culture so the culture
is very much how we do things around
here
and a useful model to understand culture
is the onion model
and in an onion model you have the outer
layer of the onion
which directs our behavior which is the
formal guidelines
you know officially what we state we're
going to do this is then
implemented into actual processes and
workflows of how we're going to do
things
but really what drives our
decision-making process
is our underlying assumptions now these
are unconscious beliefs
these are things we are unaware of that
are driving the decisions and the
concept behind the
onion model is that it's easier to
change the outer layers of the onion
than the inner
layers of the onion but if you actually
want to change practice
you have to change the heart and mind
and tackle those unconscious beliefs
and if i ever think about what i think
is driving our
decision-making process it's but it's
not possible to include both sexes i
couldn't justify it from a three-hour
perspective it's going to double the
number of animals
you know and there's no benefit to
included women we've done all this
research to date with just one sex and
it has delivered there isn't going to be
a difference here
and these underlying beliefs are the
ones
that are triggering the failure to make
change to our practice
so what's useful then to think about is
that when you're trying to make change
for an individual how do they
emotionally react to the change that
you're trying to
deliver and so this is um kerberos
change curve that was originally
developed for the concept of grief
and has since been applied by businesses
to business
changes that are needed so you know you
have your initial reaction of shocker
denial and anger
where you then try to bargain the issue
away which can lead to depression
and hopefully you move forward to
acceptance
now if we relate that more to a business
scenario what we're hoping to see as
people start to embrace the change is
that they start to experiment with the
idea
and then they'll make a decision whether
to um
be open to the idea or not be open to
the idea and hopefully they'll integrate
that into their practice and the thing
to note about the change curve is that
people
move through this curve at a different
rate and
also that the initial reaction when you
ask people
or suggest an idea to them is shock deny
and anger
you know basically resistance and so you
shouldn't take it personally you need to
ride that emotional reaction
and see it for what it is it's um fear
of the change that you're proposing
and that you need to keep revisiting the
idea so that you can drive that change
forward
and the other thing to note that i think
is useful is that
if you've been working this maybe as a
manager for a while that you will have
traveled this curve
and been coming out the other end when
you present this to your team
or other people they're going to be back
at the beginning so you have to accept
that people will be at different points
in this curve
so what we need to look for are
strategies that help people
move along this curve so gary you
has written numerous books talking about
influence tactics
and he says that these strategies can
have three reactions
they can lead to commitment reluctance
compliance or resistance
so resistance is um actively digging
your heels in
and undermining what people are
suggesting you know
saying that's a stupid idea because of
this recruiting others to the resistant
cause
reluctance compliance is that when
people will do it when you're looking at
them or you're sat with them
but commitment is what we really need
which is people become advocates
for the idea that you're proposing so
what strategies could we use and well
here are some of them and he
you know gary group them into two types
positive strategies and negative
strategies positive strategies led to
commitment
and negative strategies led to
resistance so the positive strategies
that
he suggested were things such as
rational persuasion such as this
this talk debating and discussing this
very idea
to try and win the hearts and minds of
you that we should be considering sex
as a biological variable we could have
exchanged which in a way is the
naih have done they're not going to try
and win your hearts and mind but if you
want their funding you're going to need
to have to do
it there's a consultation process a
consultation is another strategy because
you start to only pick
why people aren't embracing sex as a
biological variable
is it there's a skill gap is it um they
don't know how to manage the welfare
issue is it a misconception that it's
going to double their animal numbers
we can also do an inspirational appeal
we can highlight examples where this
practice is run such as in the jackson
lab most of their behavioral studies
are run with both sexes and that is
considered a world-leading institute
now negative strategies are pressure you
will do this
you know and then people just dig in
their heels they just hit with the anger
and they don't move any further forward
on that cycle of embracing that change
now there's two strategies that gary put
in negative so legitimizing now this
atomizing to me is a little bit like
inspirational appeals if i
say the jackson lab are doing it it can
come across as that i'm saying
they're doing it so you should be doing
it so it comes across as a pressure
strategy
so it depends on whether you can do it
as inspiration
or as a pressure approach and coalition
building can be a really valuable
resource in driving change
but it depends on how the coalition work
if they then just jump to providing
pressure
it isn't going to be successful if
instead the coalition
work to do rational persuasion
inspiration and consultation
then it will be successful within an
organization
so this tool here is the um
is a force field analysis and what you
do is you quantify the forces
driving the change and quantify the
forces resisting the change on a
qualitative scale of one to four
and if the force is resisting change are
stronger than the forces driving change
there will be no change
the status quo will be maintained so if
you want to drive change
you have to strengthen the driving
forces and you have to weaken the
resisting forces so that you can defrost
the current status quo to re-freeze in a
new situation
so if we look at the forces driving
change well there's women's health now
that is graining
gaining power at the moment women are
gaining a voice
so um that is becoming a more
significant force
there's the replicability crisis again
something that's gaining
uh journals have an influence funders
and then i put in light gray these are
groups that can have a lot of
influence but it depends on your
institute there could be ethical boards
could be quite powerful that driving has
changed
the institute culture and how they
approach it
will set the standard of what is normal
within your entities
and the leadership the management
leadership either within your
professional bodies or within your
institute can have a lot of impact
on this but you can see from the dark
grain that the actual forces driving
change are quite small which would
explain why the status quo has been
maintained
what's resisting change is in very much
our culture
the three-hour interpretation that we
have to use as minimal animals as
possible and we can only
do this through using one sex because we
don't quite understand how power is
calculated or how to use it two-way
anova
that's not how we do it around here i've
always done it this way and so there's
lots of resistance
arising from that there are some
concerns about money
and whilst you might not be doubling the
number of animals you might be using
animals in different cages that could
play out
there is an increased analysis
complexity and practicalities and
there's a belief in the values
but most of these are cultural and the
misconceptions
so these forces can be weakened if
we focus our minds on that
so with that in mind what we need is an
institute level plan how can we drive
change wind in an institute and
professor john cotter
who from harvard has written numerous
man
books on this and one of the 1995 he put
forward this eight step
change process for leading change and
what i like about it is that
he talks about how all the early steps
are about leadership
and the later steps are about management
because
you have to have the leadership steps so
that you win the hearts and minds and
change that inner core of the onion
model
and instead of jumping what we normally
do is we jump to how we're going to
practically change these activities on
the ground and what works dreams are
going to change
which is the focus and the management
stages and that's not going to work
he talks about how you have to work
through the stages sequentially though
some of them will start to be running
simultaneously and he also highlights
that you have to get all the way through
to the end
or any progress you make will be lost
and people will revert back to historic
behavior
so the first steps are around creating
urgency a purning platform which the nih
is doing very well for us
that you know if you want their money
you need to embrace sex
as a biological variable and then
suggest forming a powerful coalition
to then do the latest data ships to
provide that leadership
using people all across the organization
people have influence in the animal
houses
who are key players in the therapy areas
your key place in the ethical decisions
they're the people that can drive this
change but you will need the figurehead
as well from the professional bodies or
the incidents
you need to create a vision for change
and that vision needs to be a sound bite
it needs to be something that you can
quickly understand and get your hearts
in it can't be
a four-page document that nobody's
really going to read is going to be
signed and put in online and the reason
it's got to be the soundbite is you have
to communicate the vision with high
repetition and it talks in the books he
talks about how much information we
receive in a typical two-month process
so if someone says there's a new
initiative does a talk
um does a poster initiate a presentation
that's just gonna go and that's very
interesting and it drifts away to
nothing
if we really want this to change it has
to be something that we're talking about
numerously frequently and has been
raised multiple times in this area for
it truly to have an impact
and only then when we've done those
steps can we start to think about
removing the obstacles
removing the blockers that prevent
people from doing this
so we can create short-term wins when
you create the short-term wins we're
helping to maintain the energy to keep
going forward
to help communicate the vision and to
keep everyone
and that sense of urgency going and you
can use this
to refine your vision and to refine the
communication going forward
and only for these cycles will you
anchor the change in the culture so that
it truly
embeds as a new practice
so that's a sort of a business
management
perspective on it but i also had the
wonderful opportunity of
reading a sociological exploration of
the issue because i
got to read annika gomper's master's
dissertation at cambridge university
and she interviewed nine different
scientists in the us
to ask them what did they think about
sex as a biological
variable in their research and
sociological exploration is qualitative
research looking for patterns of meaning
or things
and she identified three different
themes
and said that they were conflicting so
the three things were generalizability
avoiding complexity and practicality
she highlighted how all the scientists
completely believed that it was really
important to research to understand
variation
to understand the biological story and
the difference what is happening
requires us to explore variations so it
was really
important to consider sex as a
biological variable
but we need to avoid complexity
to make progress in science we reduce
complexity we have to
simplify all this variation that could
be influencing the story into a simple
testing space so we can um
make a decision and communicate our
finding and incrementally step forward
the science
and so there are practicality concerns
and she's not talking about the
practicality of running experiments
she's talking about the practicality of
the scientific process
because there's a mediated tension
between the generalizability of our
conclusions we want to make a general
conclusion about what we found
and avoiding complexity if we want to
make a conclusion we can't say well it
depends on this age and this sex and
this diet
because we sort of get lost amongst the
trees we're trying to convert the
question into a doable problem
so we are actively avoiding looking for
a sex difference because we want a
simple answer
we need some examples where people have
actually done this and
you know and show us a way forward and
through that
it will become much easier for us
so in conclusion sex bias is culturally
embedded in our research pipelines it is
impacting the reporting the design and
the analysis
now precision medicine is touted as the
future
and we typically focus on differences in
genetic factors environmental lifestyle
but i would argue the set considering
the sex of the patient provides an easy
win to optimize the health care
so that should be our first protocol and
researchers suggest that sex
is a significant source of variation for
both invi and in vitro
so whilst we've not before looked that
doesn't mean that it isn't playing a
role in the story
this isn't an individual science issue
but a scientific practice
issue we need as a community
to actively be discussing these issues
to support scientists to be more mindful
of sex as a biological available in our
pipelines
i'd like to acknowledge numerous people
who've worked me over the years
who have helped me along with the story
particularly the impc
and the statisticians in tel aviv
university
in israel thank you very much for
listening i hope you enjoyed the talk
you